[Musique]
bonsoir l'or et londres lors de
nouvelles médailles pour les français en
tir à l'arc et en voile
retour sur ces médailles dans quelques
instants mais d'abord l'ombre le rêve
est passé pour michel berger le chanteur
compositeur l'un des plus doués de sa
génération est mort la nuit dernière à
saint tropez victime d'une crise
cardiaque
l'auteur de starmania compagnons de
france gall s'est écroulé chez lui à
ramatuelle
après une partie de tennis il avait 44
ans béatrice nivois discret michel
berger l'était toujours pourtant
l'auteur compositeur interprète a
imprimé sa marque à toute une génération
de la chanson française avec son éternel
allure d'étudiant michel berger avait su
imposer son style
un son bien particulier mélange de pop
et de techno qui le faisait aimer de
tous tellement difficiles à venir que
est tellement fragile
l'idée de la vie qu'elles sont tellement
fragile à cet âge là
sans vraiment des choses je suis un
petit peu je me sens encore très proche
et avaient les noms
et j'ai je ressens beaucoup de choses en
commun avec avec ce personnage
il avait écrit pour bourvil travailler
pour véronique sanson pendant six ans
composée pour françoise hardy sa
rencontre avec johnny hallyday avait
abouti un album rock n roll attitude
mais surtout michel berger a relancé la
carrière de france gall en écrivant la
déclaration en 1974
désormais ils ne se quitteront plus
marié femme ils auront deux enfants une
entente parfaite également en studio il
lui écrira de nombreux albums tous des
succès
feagles ppp fait une descente il ya des
chansons mais aussi des opéras rock
starmania en 78 véritable trion qui
révèle au grand public daniel balavoine
fabienne thibeault les deux derniers
spectacles la légende de jimmy ou
marilyn montreuil ont eu moins de succès
c'était le 15 juin
michel berger et france gall avait sorti
un premier album comme un double jeu
dont la chance aux vedettes était laissé
passer les rêves
des ans
je vende
by blanc
[Musique]
où les nuits sont ils ont
le temps
tous se lèvent
maintenant
à ramatuelle où il passait
habituellement ses vacances en famille
où il venait parfois seul pour écrire
c'est aujourd'hui la consternation
laurence bas dont c'est ici à l'hôpital
de saint tropez que repose dans la plus
grande discrétion le corps de michel
berger véritablement terrassé hier soir
à son domicile de ramatuelle par une
crise cardiaque à l'âge de 44 ans le
drame s'est produit vers 20 heures alors
que le chanteur compositeur disputait
une partie de tennis avec l'un de ses
proches dans sa propriété il s'est
subitement effondré sur le court
les pompiers rapidement sur place n'ont
pu que constater le décès autre pizana
sa plage favorite comme sur la place des
lices à saint tropez
on est stupéfait c'est un grand qui
parent sait combien ce bourg comme tous
ces gens là c'est c'est vraiment un
digne représentant de la chanson
française et qui à mon avis fait le tour
du monde
revis starmania michel berger a présenté
garçon pour qui avaient du talent alors
le corps de michel berger sera transféré
cette nuit à paris pour y être inhumé
dans la plus grande discrétion comme le
souhaitent ses proches et ce sera jeudi
au cimetière de montmartre françois
mitterrand envoyé un message de
condoléances à la famille de michel
berger le producteur les aussi le
compositeur et le chanteur sont ce soir
unanimement salué par la profession
écoutez jérôme savary le metteur en
scène michel berger avait composé la
musique de son dernier spectacle
maryline de montreuil connu à l'occasion
de sa deuxième comédie musicale la
légende de jimmy qu'on va d'ailleurs
monté au canada au mois de septembre et
qu'on va monter en pensant à lui bien
sûr et il aimait le théâtre il aimait le
la scène il aimait l'art vivant c'était
pas un homme qui se contentait
simplement de d'empocher ses royalties
il avait une écoute des autres ils
étaient ouverts à l'extérieur elle
n'était pas du tout renfermé sur lui
même et surtout c'était un type qui
était profondément honnête était
vraiment honnête je me souviens par
exemple que la première fois qu'il m'a
fait écouter les chansons de la légende
de jimmy ils n'osaient même pas se
mettre au piano pour me chanter ses
chansons
alors que moi je trouvais que c'était un
privilège d'être chez michel face à lui
et et d'avoir michel berger qui chante
et qui qui joue pour pour moi tout seul
non il était timide c'était un homme
réservé et modeste légère accalmie
aujourd'hui à sarajevo tandis que sur
kiel dans le monde des rumeurs sur
l'existence de camps de la mort serbes
en bosnie deux camps auquel la croix
rouge n'a pas pu avoir accès selon des
témoignages publiés aux états unis des
milliers de civils seraient enfermés
parfois massacrés dans cette guerre
civile où les manipulations sont monnaie
courante
toutes les atrocités reste plausible
plaire sébastien des milliers de civils
hommes femmes enfants et vieillards
serait mort de faim dans des camps de
détention serbes en bosnie des camps
dans lesquels se pratiquerait aussi la
torture c'est le quotidien new yorkais
newsday qui l'annoncé dans son édition
d'hier rapportant le témoignage de deux
rescapés une information donnée au
conditionnel
mais que semble confirmer le rapport
accablant de l'onu la semaine dernière
pour l'heure aucun membre d'une
organisation internationale n'a pu
pénétrer à omar cas où vos faux désigné
comme étant des camps de la mort en
revanche le comité international de la
croix rouge a pu commencer une
inspection en plusieurs lieux de
détention nous avons eu la possibilité
de visiter lui que lui lieu de détention
particulièrement dans les villes de
banias luca de mostar de trebinje de
zenit st et de buzz en ski broad
nous avons visité et enregistré environ
4000 personnes la détention
l'arrestation la déportation le
transfert que nous réprouvons de la plus
de la manière la plus ferme se fait sur
une base ethnique ce qui est bien
évidemment en regard du droit
international humanitaire totalement
inacceptable enfin que que la guerre se
passe peut-être s'il faut qu'elle se
passe mais qu'elles se passent au moins
dans des dans des conditions qui
respecte l'humanité là la plus simple la
bosnie aujourd'hui n'est qu'une plaie
ouverte pour tous ses habitants qui
parviennent à échapper aux bombardements
au feu des francs-tireurs la route de
l'exode s'achève parfois dans un camp de
prisonniers des camps où il est
dangereux de ne pas être serbes en
croatie résultats partiels des élections
présidentielles pas de vraie surprise le
président kullmann est largement en tête
avec plus de 55% des suffrages
les croates ont voté pour la continuité
tout mal les a conduit à l'indépendance
et pour la fin de la guerre
bien que les sternes contrôle
aujourd'hui près d'un quart du
territoire croate
afrique du sud meurtre et violences ont
marqué la première journée d'une grève
nationale anti gouvernementale de deux
jours organisé par la haine si le
congrès national africain bilan de ces
dernières 24 heures plus d'une trentaine
de morts
nelson mandela avait pourtant lancé dès
hier un appel au calme
la grève a été suivie par des millions
de noirs marié d'une panne hier nous
voulons la cei proclame l'insee mais une
fois de plus c'est la violence qui a
marqué cette journée de grève générale
meurtre fusillade
au moins cinq personnes ont été tuées
aujourd'hui dont 3 ce matin au cours
d'affrontements entre policiers et
habitants de soweto
pourtant hier nelson mandela avait lancé
un appel au calme demandant aux
manifestants de respecter ces consignes
pacifique
discipline non violence mais le leader
de la haine c'est à vous qu'il ne
contrôle pas l'ensemble de ses militants
incontrôlable aussi les partisans de
l'inkatha le parti zoulou principal
rival de la nc et qui considère la grève
générale comme une déclaration de guerre
menaçant même de représailles tout ce
qui empêcherait les non-grévistes
d'aller travailler pour le président
frédéric de claire la tension est telle
en afrique du sud que la haine c'est par
cette manifestation ne fait qu'accroître
la violence et pour faire face aux
débordements le gouvernement déployés
5000 policiers dans le site et noir mais
là encore leur présence ressentie comme
une provocation n'a fait qu'envenimer la
situation
pourtant malgré la violence la haine
c'est ne voyait pas d'autres armes que
cette grève massive pour contraindre le
gouvernement blanc à avancer sur la voie
des réformes
après des mois de négociations
infructueuses il demande la mise en
place d'un gouvernement intérimaire
d'unité nationale et la tenue d'
élections multiraciales avant la fin de
l'année paradoxe l'un des buts des
manifestants est aussi d'obtenir des
mesures concrètes pour enrayer la
violence endémique qui endeuillent les
cités noires
la boîte noire de l'airbus qui s'est
écrasé vendredi dernier dans l'himalaya
a été retrouvée l'accident a fait je
vous le rappelle 113 victimes
et avant même la lecture de cette boîte
noire et l' écoute des conversations de
l'équipage
l'hypothèse de problèmes techniques
prévaut en bourreaux après le
registraire des conversations de
l'équipage retrouvé hier la boîte noire
vient d'être dégagée de la carcasse de
l'airbus a310 300 son examen permettra
peut être de comprendre les raisons de
l'accident
seule certitude aujourd'hui le pilote
avait signalé des problèmes techniques
quelques minutes avant que l'avion
s'écrase sur les contreforts de
l'himalaya à 3500 mètres d'altitude
certains responsables de l'aviation
civile avance d'ores et déjà la thèse
d'une panne de réacteur autre hypothèse
avancée vendredi un mauvais
fonctionnement de l'altimètre mauvais
fonctionnement fatale compte tenu de la
visibilité restreinte au moment de
l'accident
car quelle que soit la cause du crash le
pilote a de toute façon été gêné par la
pluie incessante et le brouillard des
conditions atmosphériques difficiles qui
ont également compliqué le travail des
800 sauveteurs
seule une vingtaine de corps ont pu être
dégagés des débris de l'avion éparpillés
sur deux kilomètres carrés 113 personnes
se trouvaient à bord de l'airbus
aucune n'a survécu à l'accident
septième et dernière semaine du procès
du sang contaminé la parole est à la
défense
tâche difficile après six semaines
d'accusations centre air au centre des
débats cet après midi l'état des
connaissances sur le sida en 1985
une ligne de défense tracé par l'avocat
de robert né terre et qui devrait être
reprise pour les autres inculpés au
palais de justice de paris à manger
incongrue au milieu des statuts de la
salle d'audience
un poste de télévision muet depuis six
semaines
aujourd'hui la défense il a fait
projeter une bande vidéo de cinq minutes
des interviews de spécialistes du sida
en 85 et professeurs rozembaum d'une
part le professeur la bourriche d'autre
part et beaucoup d'autres
même le professeur bernard ont déclaré
il ya quelques jours cette audience que
il savait tout du sida et que si on
entend aujourd'hui leurs déclarations de
1980 pour voir qu'ils étaient dans le
plus grand doute qui parlait de
fantasmes kiffar années d'incertitude la
stratégie de la défense est donc clair
prouvé qu'en 85
les inculpés n'étaient pas les seuls à
sous-estimer les risques alors pourquoi
et eux seuls devraient ils payer
d'autant continue la défense que seule
une expertise pourrait déterminer
lesquels parmi les 62 parties civiles
ont été contaminés pendant la période
cruciale de mars à octobre 85
une façon de sous-entendre que certaines
plaintes ont été déposées de manière
abusive
le seul moment où les familles des
victimes a réagi c'est lorsque la
défense évoque le fils de lundi mettra
inculpé devenu subitement aveugle à la
suite d'une tumeur au cerveau
sans doute l'avocat espère est-il une
réaction de compassion celle inverse qui
s'est produit
sourire ironique haussement d'épaulés
visiblement les familles des victimes
pensent qu'à leur douleur et à
elle-seule maastricht le non au
référendum progresse mais le oui
demeurent majoritaires selon un sondage
ifop que publiera demain libération 57%
des français voteraient oui à la
ratification du traité si le référendum
avait lieu dimanche prochain
43% 5 % de plus que le mois dernier
votre et non et puis la moitié des
personnes interrogées ne se disent pas
encore sûrs de leur choix
arrestation ce matin à bordeaux d'un des
responsables présumés de l'oedt et axa
pouilly il est considéré comme le
responsable des collectifs des réfugiés
basques espagnols
bénéficient de lui-même en france du
statut de réfugié politique
les autres images de l'actualité en
france comme hanté par leasing ou de
[Musique]
l'épave de l'avion de tourisme disparu
dimanche après son décollage de la baule
a été repéré ce matin dans la baie du
mont-saint-michel deux corps ont été
retrouvés non loin de l'appareil les
recherches se poursuivent pour tenter de
localiser les corps des deux autres
passagers le crash du monde moteur
demeure pour l'instant inexpliqué la
balise de détresse n'a pas été utilisé
troisième attentat à l'explosif perpétré
la nuit dernière contre un sauna
marseillais l'explosion a fait deux
blessés légers deux autres sauna du
centre-ville ont connu ces derniers
jours en sort similaire
les policiers marseillais évoque une
guerre des saunas et privilégient
l'hypothèse d'un racket
le jeune homme a été retrouvé mort après
l'incendié qui s'est déclaré la nuit
dernière dans un cabaret parisien du
xviiie arrondissement
le feu d'origine encore indéterminée
aurait pris naissance dans la réserve de
l'établissement
c'est en portant secours à une vieille
dame sérieusement blessé que le jeune
homme a trouvé la mort quatre pompiers
ont également été blessés au cours de l'
incendie
la belle moisson de médailles françaises
aux jeux olympiques de barcelone la
collection s'est enrichie de deux
nouvelles pièces en or l'une revient aux
duettistes de la voix l'équipage du
tornado yves loday nicolas inard l'autre
à sébastien flute 20 ans champion de tir
à l'arc barcelone jaffe libyen extrême
concentration maîtrise totale de soi et
résistance au stress toutes les qualités
de sébastien flute aujourd'hui déjà
champion d'europe de la spécialité et
champion du monde en salle sébastien
flute 20 ans a réussi à garder la tête
froide sur le parc des sports du vall
d'hebron né à brest mais licencié au
stade clermontois ce jeune homme de 20
ans a lutté flèche après flèches contre
le sud coréen jae won chung pour
finalement l'emporter 110 à 107 grâce à
2 10 lors de la dernière série
premier devant le coréen du sud chung et
le britannique terry sébastien flute
rapporte à la france sa 6e médaille d'or
la septième médaille d'or est arrivé
moins d'une demi heure plus tard en
provenance du port de barcelone cette
fois en tornado yves loday et nicolas
hénard ont dominé les équipages
américains et australiens
le barreur yves l'aude et 37 ans du club
de la baule est très expérimenté
puisqu'il a déjà participé aux jeux de
moscou et de los angeles
quant à nicolas hénard qu'il est
champion olympique en titre associé à le
déroff il avait déjà décroché l'or à
séoul les deux hommes au caractère très
affirmé ont su s'unir pour vaincre dans
la déroute du sprint français non
inscription de marie-rose abandon ce
matin de trois balles dans les séries du
200 m gilles quénéhervé lui a failli
revenir de loin disqualifier ce matin il
a fallu l'initiative des journalistes
d'antenne 2 fr3 qui ont fait visionner
la bande au jury pour le remettre dans
la course du quasiment jamais vu aux
jeux olympiques dominique champeau ce
matin 10 heures au départ de sa série
qualificative du 200 m gilles quénéhervé
est confiant la forme est là comparable
presque à celle qui lui valu de devenir
vice-champion du monde de la spécialité
en 87
sur le plan sportif ce rush matinal ne
fut qu'une formalité pour lui jusqu'à ce
qu'un juge ne prononce sa
disqualification pour avoir mis le pied
dans le couloir voisin justement c'est
tellement problème depuis le début de
saison j'essaie vraiment le travail est
de faire attention à cette ligne parce
que je savais qu'il y aurait il pourrait
vous pouvez y avoir les deux
disqualifications et là je vois pas où
je marche je mange pas
sincèrement on voit la ligue ou
vêtements sur l'appui gauche oui on se
marche pas sur la ligne sur aucun moment
alors je comprends pas du tout je crois
qu'il faut porter une réclamation il
faut attendre parce que est ce que
dominique leglou m'entends oui oui vous
pouvez peut-être suggérer à gilles
quénéhervé de porter la cassette au le
ralenti
des juges c'est ainsi que sur
l'initiative de antenne 2 et fr3 les
juges après une heure de visionnage pur
prononcer la requalification de
quénéhervé à fait unique dans les
annales des jeux face aux documents et
gilles été disqualifié c'était
regrettable parce qu'il n'a fait aucune
faute c'était logique jusqu'au bout sa
compétition rendue à son bonheur en fin
d'après midi gilles quénéhervé donnera
longtemps l'impression de pouvoir
accompagner l'illustrissime mike marsh
en demi finale hélas le film l'a encore
fait foi au terme de cette série
qualificative
il sera bien d'éliminer mais par le
chronomètre cette fois
[Applaudissements]
marie josé pérec
elle s'est qualifiée il ya quelques
minutes pour la finale du 400 m dames
elle a réalisé le meilleur temps de ces
demi-finales en 49 secondes et 40
centièmes
elle est plus que jamais favorites pour
la finale que ce convoi
mercredi soir l'autre française elsa de
vassoigne est en huitième de sa série
phare dont en 52 secondes et 85
centièmes et limites ni
cerexhe la première en tennis le dernier
français en lice fabrice santoro a été
éliminé en quarts de finale par le
croate ivan iv beach qui est désormais
au moins médaille de bronze première
médaille pour la croatie ivanisevic veut
de l'or pour les croates les chiffres et
par la guerre difficile travaille
d'ailleurs à barcelone que celui des
journalistes de l'ancienne yougoslavie
malgré la guerre qui déchire les
républiques ils doivent cohabiter dans
un même local ils s'ignorent ne
parvenant pas malgré l'esprit olympique
cher au baron de coubertin à oublier la
guerre
reportage caroline si mme branchaud et
servent drago et croate
tous deux sont journalistes et couvre le
même événement mais pour eux il n'y a
pas de trêve olympique
ils ont choisi leur classe à l'opposé
l'un de l'autre et ne se parlent pas ces
hommes qui s'est vite sont pourtant
obligés de vivre et de travailler
ensemble dans le bureau de la télé ingo
slave un espace réduit
louer avant la guerre quand il
n'existait qu'une seule télé aujourd'hui
il y en a six différentes pour chaque
région bosniaques croates et serbes sont
donc forcés de tous à douter mais
personne ne peut oublier le bruit des
armes
j'ai le coeur qui me fait mal mais on
est obligé de travailler ensemble
cet homme est serbe là aussi je suis
contrainte de parler avec lui
normalement lorsque vous parlez des
politiques non pour les visas pour
entrer dans des discussions qu'il ne
mènerait à rien d'une part elle pourrait
envenimer les relations
la trêve des jeux n'a pas eu lieu la
guerre des territoires continuent la
radio serbe s'est attribué les plus
grands bureaux la radio croate se
retrouve coincé dans onze mètres carrés
ami autrefois ils s'ignorent aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le plus difficile c'est de voir des gens
avec qui on a travaillé pendant 15 ans
et depuis la guerre plus rien il nous
demande jamais ce qui se passe en
croatie
si nous avons besoin des deux enfants
sont encore en vie les athlètes
bosniaques et croates participent pour
la première fois ces jeux sous leurs
propres couleurs
mais ils ne peuvent pas oublier ce
qu'ils ont laissé là bas beaucoup de
sportifs se battre sur le front des
heures certains sont gravement blessés à
tout le monde comme d'autres sont morts
autre bonne nouvelle écoute l'avion à
tous les bons lutter trois sets
il a été tué en défendant dubrovnik pour
ses hommes la guerre n'est pas une image
entrevue à la télévision mais une
souffrance quotidienne
à leurs yeux la paix olympique n'est
qu'une illusion
et si hergé s'était trompé objectif lune
le whisky du capitaine haddock doit-il
faire une bulle en apesanteur expérience
tentée ce matin avec de l'eau évidemment
par michel tonini à bord de la station
mir leçon de choses daniel durand des
premiers référence de cette véritable
leçon de choses
l'album d'hergé on a marché sur la lune
lorsque le capitaine haddock souvient du
whisky dans son verre le whisky se met
en boule et s'envole dans la cabine
deuxième référence cette manipulation
imaginé ce matin par michel tonini dans
la station orbitale mir combat doucement
verser de l'eau dans le vert miracles
l'on va rester prisonnière je vais
retourner magie peut être pas tout à
fait car les molécules d'eau restent
soudés les unes aux autres par
capillarité en clair la station orbitale
n'étant pratiquement plus soumise à la
pesanteur les molécules d'eau contenue
dans le vert n'ont plus aucune raison
d'être a tiré vers le bas
or d'hubert lorsque celui ci est
retourné conclusions en fait ce n'est
pas hergé qui s'est trompé mais le
capitaine haddock qui avait trop bu tout
de suite météo complète de fabienne
amiach puis dès 20h dans quelques
petites minutes retour à barcelone soir
3 vous sera présenté à 22h30 par
catherine m'approche je vous retrouve
demain à 12h45 et 19h pour le 19 mai
toulon